hello everyone thank you for joining my
talk i'm honored to be an invited
speaker and want to thank neuroscience
2021 and lab roots for hosting this
conference
i want to start with just saying a
little bit about myself and my work i'm
a supervising psychologist at harbour
ucla medical center
where i've worked for the last 20 years
or so i'm also the clinical director of
the safe harbor trauma recovery center
team that started in 2019 based on a
grant from the california victim
compensation board
and i'm excited about doing that work
with that team
and i'm also an associate professor at
ucla david geffen school of medicine
and some of the work i do
focuses of course on trauma but also on
adults with chronic mental illness who
are also high utilizers of emergency
services
and also population that engages in uh
suicidal behaviors and non-suicidal
self-injury
this topic of compassion fatigue is
really near and dear to my heart
having been on a team and served in a
leadership position
where a member of the team did complete
a suicide and this was years ago
but still
looming for me to think about and
attuning to in any team i work in
what is the responsibility and what are
measures of self-care and dealing with
compassion fatigue that really helps
steam thrive and grow
so i want to start with a quote
by victor frankl
that which is to give light must endure
burning and i actually asked my team to
reflect on this quote
and to give me some experiences from
their work and even from their lives
on what that means to them and many
really profound messages came in
a lot about a shared journey of recovery
many people that choose to do trauma
work
have a lived experience and thinking
about the
the burn that they felt in their life
either through intergenerational trauma
or specific traumas they endured that
led them to be here and do this work and
i want to share one particular story of
a psychologist who's working from with a
refugee from el salvador who was really
struggling with the attorneys and the
asylum procedure and wasn't able to be
there for her for her father's death
when he died in el salvador
part of it was due to
some miscommunication with the attorneys
and the letter not being written and
this is what the psychologist wrote
she was angry at the system at her
lawyer and at me
i felt that burn i held space for her
and her emotion knowing that her grief
was more than two part there was a third
part of injustice and barriers that she
had to face and continues to face as an
immigrant who had to flee her home for
safety and is navigating the complex
waters of feeling acknowledged and
legitimate in this new country
we discovered the light in the burn that
her grief was finally labeled shared and
acknowledged warmth and connection were
present
but so was the pain
so a little bit about safe harbor trauma
recovery center and this is uh harbor
ucla harbor ucla is has a resilient
story of its own
being the first port of embarkation for
the army in 1942 many of the buildings
are still the same buildings from 42 and
still standing
and this is our vision for a better
newer facade in the future on the lower
picture there
and the trauma team works to promote
healing recovery and growth for trauma
survivors and their families but we do
really more than that we also
combine our efforts with community
collaborators which include law
enforcement a particular organization
called fostering unity that provides
stabilization and care
to foster families resource families and
to also caregivers who are biological
caregivers and to the children and
we're working with another organization
after innocence that looks at
projects that help paralyse
that were exonerated
so essentially people who are convicted
of crimes unjustly and are exonerated
and are re-entering the community and
these services uh really show the vast
impact of compassion fatigue not just
for our team but teams around the county
and at harbor and other projects is with
nurses and nurse suicide is pretty much
up there with physician suicide these
days so for physicians
it's the largest group that completes
suicide and followed by nurses so really
thinking of compassion fatigue and how
to make some changes through actual
interventions using community resilience
models and some other models that i'll
talk about
so my talk will focus on
the effect of covet 19 specifically and
thinking that more globally about
compassion fatigue we're going to review
some stress models that are old and new
we're going to talk about
the concepts of compassion fatigue and
burnout and maybe add a reframing less
pathological view of compassion fatigue
and burnout
also think about positive psychology the
new wave and not just thinking about
happiness and well-being and then
celibates talked about flourishing but
also thinking about the upside of the
dark side negative emotions as well and
leading to mature gratitude and thinking
about how that leads to actual refrain
of resilience stories
so generally in terms of covet 19 impact
a new study by
cover broca in 2020
showed that 30 to 70
of health workers have depression
anxiety
acute stress disorders
some suicidal ideation increased to up
to 10 percent
as well and this particular
study that i'm naming in my slide
is a large survey showing that 7 in 10
health professionals indicated that the
pandemic is the most stressful time of
their entire professional career
there's always a silver lining i love
this study that when asked about whether
you think there are any positives that
come out of this pandemic 88 of the
respondents said yes in this 2021 study
primarily the areas that they described
growth in uh family relationships about
50
describe that a greater appreciation for
life involving reassessment of personal
values
increased spiritual growth for almost 20
percent
discovering and embracing new
opportunities and possibilities
so thinking about there's always another
side to
adversity and stress there is the silver
lining
that you can
decide to focus on
so thinking about coped and the specific
impact
of kovid is that's really new in a
modern age is the chronic the chronicity
of the stress the social isolation
having unclear prognosis even now with
vaccinations
and the multiple social media
misinformation about it
the confusion and uncertainty about
health and health behaviors
also being positioned unfamiliar public
health measures and now sheltering place
is lifted but
really even negotiating another
potential surge and what measures would
be instituted again
the pervasiveness of human life that's
lost in a modern era where we expect
modern medicine to be able to tackle it
and human life is still lost
the unique economic hardships that and
that has an impact on families so high
rates of unemployment
higher rates of domestic violence and
child abuse cases up to about 35
increase
in child abuse cases looking at one
international study that looks at europe
asia and the us
also interesting there are less ed
department visits in the
2020 year compared to 2019 but there are
more visits to the ed by children and
women who required hospitalization so i
think the issue here is access rather
than actual severity or increase in in
abuse cases
there are unique economic i'm sorry
there's health disparities as well that
are similar to what we know of in terms
of people of color but in terms of the
pandemic it's even more startling to
think about and read those
health disparities
in some counties in the south
like in louisiana for example
uh 70 of the infections are in
african-americans
whereas 30
is uh is african-americans so 30
population constitutes people of color
and specifically african-americans
in the last jama study
that looked at 131 counties in the u.s
the death rate
from
the pandemic is six-fold
for african americans compared to their
white citizens
and
it's threefold the infection rates and
this is beyond access to care or what
people usually name co-morbidities like
diabetes or have hypertension but in
reality this is more about race
determines home and issues related to
people who work in the service industry
who don't have the luxury to work from
home
housing density not owning their car or
home
and having to make some difficult
choices about
being out in the world while facing a
pandemic this is really more the issue
and then finally in terms of doing
remote work because mental health
professionals and doing virtual therapy
we really thrive on the connection with
the clients we thrive on being able to
see them and speak to them
sitting in the office or when we do
psychosocial rehabilitation the sort of
community treatment is even being out in
the community and doing field work and
that's not afforded to us anymore at
this time
gradually we started doing that again
and had to go back
to
the practice of remote work
which makes it very difficult all right
we're going to move on to stress and
describing different types of stress and
stress theories so there's the good the
bad and the chronic the good is a stress
that you anticipate and decide to take
part in such as jumping off a perfectly
good airplane or being pushed off a
building having done both like in a test
that's a really thrilling experience
there's a chronic stress in the case of
a nurse staff that
has extended and has been there for many
hours and this goes on
day and day out
and having an acute stress reaction to
some stimuli that's aversive in the
moment such as being chased by a hippo
where in some regions it's the number
one cause of death
the the number of different stress
theories spanned from the year of 1932
where
cannon talked about fight flight freeze
and then we added fawn there's also
fornicate which i'm not talking about
today but i want to focus on tend and
befriend which is a newer theory that
was developed by shelly taylor out of
ucla
and she presented it first in 2000 and
then it was finalized and written about
in 2006 and this notion is that tend and
befriend is a biobehavioral
theory that we can see in animals and
also in humans where the tending to
their young protecting their young and
befriending their social community
actually reduces stress at a biological
level so there are several studies that
show
that
having an experience of being
learning about the diagnosis of cancer
in a loved one and having one group
send positive
thoughts and wishes for the person
diagnosed
and versus a group that's not told to do
that the group that is told to engage in
essentially tending and befriending
behaviors
show a reduction in cortisol levels both
in blood and saliva
another interesting study is one that
involves using a huggable device using
in a virtual platform so actually having
something you can hug as you're talking
to someone else and the study showed
again decrease in cortisol level and
both blood and saliva in that study so
tending befriending is an important
component and to kind of drive that home
and you might be wondering why is there
a lioness licking what looks like an
antelope and not eating it and so the
next video is actually a
story of a lioness in
sub-saharan that adopted a oryx antelope
calf
as her own and this was after she lost
her own cub
and her dealing of a stress in a
stress response is to actually tend and
befriend
another species altogether
the unthinkable happened
word spread that a lioness in kenya's
samboro reserve had taken an antelope
calf alive and was guarding it as her
own
i couldn't believe my ears when i first
heard about the adoption i just thought
you know that's absolute nonsense give
it a few hours and that lioness will
definitely eat the calf
saba douglas hamilton is wildlife
conservationist for the save the
elephant trust she rushed to the reserve
to see for herself the lioness and the
baby oryx antelope in one of the oddest
animal bonds ever seen and all of a
sudden
there was this completely unheard of
situation on our hands
of a predator that had adopted its prey
she was named kaminak meaning the
blessed one
i think many people felt that this was
you know had to be a message from god um
this was a miracle this was you know the
lion and the lamb laying down together
[Music]
and kaminak
really seemed to be infatuated by the
baby
so they'd walk together and
life flop down under a tree and curl up
next to each other
um
it was very moving all right sorry to
say there is a grim ending to the story
and probably not what you think the
lioness did not eat the baby antelope
however after two weeks of not being
able to approach the watering hole or
hunting for food sources they had to go
down and in the watering hole a big line
jumped out and ate the baby antelope and
for modern remembering the story she
repeated this adoption process with
another
baby antelope and i want to think maybe
anthropomorphically thinking about this
that this was her way of sending
befriending to overcome the stress
response we were talking about
[Music]
so i want to talk about stress-related
concepts that brings us to the heart of
this discussion which is thinking of
burnout secondary trauma vicarious
trauma and compassion fatigue
and if you want to think of
sorry the terms here
burnout and secondary trauma
are kind of discrete and maybe more
potentially global
so there's this discrete of secondary
trauma more global of burnout but both
contribute to more chronic
compassion fatigue
and i want to add here that often we
think about compassion fatigue
and even burnout as pathological it's
what people don't want to experience
i want to suggest to us that there is an
adaptive function for feeling compassion
fatigue and experiencing it and this
quote comes to mind it is no measure of
health to be well adjusted to a
profoundly sick society by judo
krishnamurti and what that speaks to me
about is when the system is not fitting
and what you're trying to fit into
is not working for you the compassion
fatigue is an adaptive response to
realizing
i need to do something different this is
not working so rather than thinking
about it as symptomatic and pathological
how do we start reframing it to think
about it as a warning signal something
has to change in my life
i need a more value-aligned endeavor i
need to change my priorities i need to
think about more meaning
and so thinking about this quote and
thinking about reframing this compassion
fatigue idea
so burnout as
defined as a state of emotional physical
and mental exhaustion that's caused by
excessive and prolonged stress and often
we think about role overload just doing
too many things or having role conflict
trying to be in two places at the same
time
having a young child
age five myself i know that very well
and thinking about how do we intervene
so in hospitals where some measures were
utilized either helping healers heal and
h3 which we have at harbor or some more
precise trainings or more
theory and evidence
driven
interventions like community resilience
model
actually proved really successful so in
one study
there is a reduction of 30 percent
in burnout
and this amounted to
over 6 000 fear infections for a vast
annual saving cost
up to 68 million
and the interventions that were used in
many of the studies are
things typical like h3 or
any kind of interventions that teach a
person how to come back to a resilient
zone which i'll talk about a little
later other concepts related to stress
and compassion fatigue that contributes
to it is discrete vicarious trauma
incidents
and that is the process through which
the therapist inner experience is
negatively transformed through empathic
engagement and this is the more that you
feel the empathy the more likely you are
to be impacted and the importance they
spoke about of integrating and moving
through it
yourself as well as your work with the
client
and the measures are rather high
80 to 86 percent specifically nurses
social workers physicians and therapists
of all kinds first responders
essentially are at risk for that based
on figly
so compassion fatigue which i've been
talking about
as the umbrella term the thinking about
that is the gradual lessening of
compassion over time
and there are stages in it that you
can experience going through them
but one thing to mention there is a
sadness that goes along with feeling
what you're feeling as an empathic
response in itself is not again a
pathological response it is that you
allow the experience of another to touch
your heart and be present with them
but if you are not uh
aware and you're not intentionally
working on separation and mirroring
uh you go through
philly's figly's ideas through certain
stages in the beginning as the zealots
phase where you're
almost overdoing you're there extra
hours you're spending hours in the nicu
unit holding
a preemie for example as a nurse
then you move through irritability
irritability with a system with others
and you slowly withdraw and then what he
calls the zombie phase where you
completely are disconnected both in your
own life with your own family and others
at work
and this can either stay as a pathology
and victimization
or move into a maturation and renewal
depending on this process i'm speaking
of and the key again is to acknowledge
you're struggling and the first step is
to acknowledge and then ask for help in
this metaphor by the time you're thirsty
you're already dehydrated so how do you
not get emotionally psychologically
dehydrated
with the work you do
there's a famous uh i guess cultural
narrative if you will of what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger and this
quote is actually from nietzsche
but also has been uh maybe sung about by
kelly clarkson and taylor swift and
thinking about whether that's true or
false really the answer is it depends it
depends uh
related to how unintegrated the trauma
is if it's unintegrated they're more
susceptible
in the sense to die
from that is the most extreme by suicide
or a prolonged stress that causes other
adversities medical adversities
so
this idea of what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger
and even in terms of post-traumatic
growth is really you need to look at it
a little more carefully what does cause
post-traumatic growth isn't
incidental self-report
retrospective studies that look at these
people reported but how does it get
grounded
in a personality factor that now changes
and this is the work recent work of
jayawakurami and blackie and also
inferna
and jayawakremi
who really talk more about prospective
studies to look at what actually leads
to post-traumatic growth and what gets
grounded as a personality trait or a
personality factor
which is really important to think about
when we think of post-traumatic growth
so the concept of neuroplasticity
at some point in the 60s was a new one
we used to think of the brain
as
unchanging or fixed and it was the work
of
a researcher by the name of michael and
mercedes i think
back in the 60s who actually sought out
to prove it that the brain is unchanging
and actually discovers the opposite so
think about his resilience in adapting
and actually creating this new field of
research that actually shows that the
brain does change in neural pathways do
actually grow in the adult brain
so not only positive
reactions and positive thoughts wire
and what
wires together fires together so the
idea of creating more positive from
creating positive
also negative emotions wired that way
which kind of explains why many trauma
survivors
associate let's say a smell
with a person who abused them and
actually wiring moves into the olfactory
lobe in the brain and so that the memory
of the scent actually is a brain
response and the aversion is a brain
response as well
so the idea is if you don't mindfully
direct the change in your brain
something else will do it for you so the
idea of
really looking at ways to create neural
pathways that are
creating flourishing thriving and
resilient stories
so the brain
automatically moves to a negativity bias
we have four negative thoughts for every
one positive thought
we look at and scan for threats
uncertainty social isolation and
fairness and this could actually impair
functioning in life and i'll use a
personal example i was deathly afraid of
sharks it was a phobia for me
so much so that i would be afraid of
them and even fresh water there are
sharks that do survive in fresh water at
least for 60 miles from what i learned
those are bull sharks which are really
dangerous for humans
so my rewiring of the brain some people
will call it even
systematic desensitization or possibly
flooding i started diving so here is my
first dive experience in oahu with a
turtle pretty harmless
then with an octopus also rather
harmless
but then it wasn't my feared object
right the feared object were sharks so
here i am with bull sharks
specifically
bull sharks in belize
so thinking about rewiring the brain
maybe was the catalyst a positive
psychology which is the study of the
conditions processes and characteristics
that contributors contribute to optimal
functioning and one of the things in the
old way of positive psychology is to
think about well-being and happiness
and martin seligman has revised the idea
of happiness and
started thinking about flow and
flourishing
actually flows from mehali
but
flourishing is more the term and now
it's developed into another segment of
positive psychology where acknowledging
and welcoming integrating the negative
the upside of the dark side idea is
really the the new wave but when we used
to study happiness we looked at factors
that contribute to it what's under our
control is 40
our genetics and happiness set point
idea where people just bounce back
depending on their genetics and then
life circumstances that
limit or
provide some obstacles
and we studied this
in order to look at how it affects
health and so this is
many many studies on gratitude and
health that looks at sleep exercise
cardiovascular health mood optimism
and many of them show improvement
cancer and heart attacks all those are
actually studies that looked at how
gratitude
improves both the prognosis from the
disease and maybe a second heart attack
if someone is not optimistic
but now we think about something called
mature gratitude which is different than
the concept of gratitude we used to
think about and mature gratitude is the
dynamic and dialectical interplay
between positive and negative life
experiences and the work of wong
primarily highlights the importance of
including incorporating attending
attuning to negative experiences
even lingering there in energy
psychology we actually focus on negative
images for a while before releasing them
and that idea is actually what we call
mature gratitude
so my antidotes to compassion fatigue
one is mindfulness practice and
mindfulness goes a long way i want to
share just a quick story
i was working with someone a high
commanding officer in a particular law
enforcement agency who was required to
come to therapy and wanted no part of it
and said he's giving me five sessions to
implement some change in his life and we
started by just doing mindfulness and
the first three sessions is all we did
observe describe participate what skills
of mindfulness
and he came back after the third session
so mindfulness essentially in terms of
non-judgmental
present focused attention
and not running to
pasture or future and not reacting
and he came back to us with the third
session saying my life has been
transformed and i was a little skeptical
but he proceeded to tell me a story
where he was
at the market in line and someone in
front of them cut in and he was about to
tell her off it was an older woman with
a baby and then handed the baby the
cashier and had a long conversation and
he was very angry and but then
remembered our mindfulness practice and
then when it finally was his turn he
came up to the cashier and he said it
was a very cute baby and she said i'm so
glad you think so is my it's my child
it's my daughter and i don't get to
spend time with her much because i work
two jobs since my husband died in the
last deployment
and he just stopped at his tracks and he
actually started crying right in the
market and this is a high commanding law
enforcement officer then came back to
session and said how in life he has been
on autopilot
reacting and being angry and irritable
and how the mindfulness practice
actually helped at least the beginning
stage of changing his life
so a daily mindfulness practice and it
doesn't mean sitting and meditating
necessarily it's just engaging in every
moment in that non-judgmental way
value aligned work daily and sometimes
if your work becomes your life like i'm
working with resource parents i'm also a
resource parent an adaptive mom of a
child so
finding ways where your work and your
life actually align so that you're
actually living
what you're doing at work and it's part
of your
meaningful life activity
reframing compassion fatigue from
pathology to meaning making which is
what i spoke of before creating more
social connections tending and
befriending on a daily basis holistic
view of health the mature gratitude
thinking about the negative thinking
about your meltdowns as important steps
in
health and maturation and thriving
and then changing traumatic stories to
resilient narratives and i'll talk a
little bit about that and resilience is
the idea that you bounce you're able to
bounce back you're able to adapt you're
able to change habits and that you
continue to do that with connection and
attention to others
and there are several principles that
relate to it
cultivating a belief in your ability
connected connecting with sources of
support talking about what's going on
being helpful
attitude of survivorship and so on and i
think what's important in creating
stories
is remembering that your goal is to
widen the resilient zone and the
community resiliency model talks about
being bounced out of your zone because
of negative experiences but using them
learning from them and coming back to a
wider zone of resilience and this is
essentially a nervous system reaction to
stress and the resilient zone is coming
back to where your parasympathetic
nervous system kicks in when you're in a
sympathetic mode
so building a resilience story is
actually a method you start at the end
how did you get through the adverse
event
when do you remember feeling safer what
were your resiliency elements what
strengths and qualities did you use to
get through it and how did you grow what
meaning did you make of the story
so last story for the day
my
experience with kovitz specifically
since the topic is coveted is that my
mom passed away from covid about a year
ago and so that's the end of the story
but the end is actually that i got to be
with her on her last moments and i got
to hold her hand
despite restrictions from the hospital
despite being told go home you can't
come in
and how do they get through it
i actually thought about
what aren't my strengths which is
speaking up which is insisting or coming
to the hospital every day in beer and
saying i must see her and they finally
let me in so my resilient story they got
to spend the last day of my mom's life
holding her hand as she did for me
when i was a baby
i'm going to end with just a quick poem
and this poem is a palodrome so
depends your about your narrative how
are you going to read it so from the top
down it reads like a terrible poem about
mistrusting people and people are
naturally unkind
right but if you read it from the bottom
it's a different narrative all together
so decide on your narrative think about
where is your resilience how are you
going to grow it how are you going to
embed it into a personality structure
that follows you wherever you go how do
you make meaning of adversity
and please continue to thrive wherever
you go
thank you